a HIGHlarious right-wing troll calls
Chris Cuomo Fredo to his face
Fredo flies off the handle and then both
Cuomo and CNN try to play the race card
to excuse him insisting that Fredo is a
slur for Italians as the only Paisano of
italian-american descent over here at
the Daily wire I will explain the
difference between words that make fun
of Italians and words that make fun of
stron see like Chris Cuomo then more
bizarre details emerge about Jeffrey
Epstein's obvious murder at the hands of
Hillary climene suicide suicide then the
culture wars heat up as 2020 Democrats
spread flagrant lies on sensitive racial
issues all that more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
suicide yeah that's the ticket that's
the ticket
this is the absolute greatest video that
has come out in at least two weeks it is
the funniest thing on the Internet
Chris Cuomo of CNN being confronted by
this right-wing troll will explain what
happened what it means why Cuomo's
defense is bogus and also maybe why we
shouldn't encourage these kind of things
but we can laugh when they happen we
will get to that in a second but first
let me tell you something on occasion I
have actually done business I mean now
my job is to kind of just make fun of
media figures and politicians but in the
old days at least I used to be involved
in growing businesses and starting
businesses and let me tell you the
problem growing businesses is the
problem that they have is that they
sometimes have this hodgepodge of
business systems so they can't know
their numbers this is this whole slew of
different systems and processors that
will keep you from knowing the actual
fundamentals of your business that's
where NetSuite comes in real handy
introducing NetSuite by Oracle the
business management software that
handles every aspect of your business
in an easy-to-use cloud platform giving
you the visibility and control you need
to grow with NetSuite you save time
money and unneeded headaches by managing
sales finance accounting orders and HR
instantly and we know there's no
difference between time and money we
know that time is money and especially
for growing businesses I've been
involved in businesses that have made a
ton of money and businesses that haven't
made a ton of money and the one thing
they have in common when you start is at
the beginning every penny counts every
dollar counts maybe more importantly
every minute counts I really wish that
we had had a system like this when we'd
started a few businesses actually that I
was involved with years ago it's an
incredible solution from NetSuite it's
why the world it's for the world's
number one cloud business system right
now NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits at
NetSuite dot-com / Knowles that is
NetSuite comm / Knowles Canada wles head
over there you'll get a free guide I
know it you don't believe that anything
is free it is free go get it you have
nothing to lose you have everything to
gain
go get your free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits
NetSuite dot-com
/ Knowles Cana wles this I was gonna go
get a lot of work done last night when I
got home I had a ton of things on the
schedule to do wanted to prepare the
show and then this video went viral on
the Internet CNN's Chris Cuomo screaming
at a trump supporter because the Trump
supporter called him Fredo which refers
to the Godfather refers to the stupid
brother in The Godfather Fredo Chris
flies off the handle and then I was just
sucked down a vortex of memes for the
rest of the night here is the beginning
thank goodness it was filmed by this
same troll ish guy who was provoking
Cuomo thank goodness it was filmed here
as Cuomo reacting to being called Fredo
my name is Chris Cuomo I'm an anchor on
your much Fredo
is from The Godfather there was a weak
brother in that year and they use it as
an Italian aspersion any new Italian
[Music]
that's the line I mean this guy's
obviously a pro just know you seemed to
be much more reasonable in person than
you do on television Chris Cuomo was
claimed that he's reacting to is that
the word Fredo referring to the brother
the stupid brother and the Godfather is
like the n-word for Italians no it's not
it it just objectively is not I don't
think it's ever been referred to that
way I am an italian-american I grew up
in the italian-american culture here in
New York right we're Fredo Cuomo is from
actually one time when I was a waiter at
a restaurant in high school I was the
waiter for Fredo's brother Andrew Cuomo
Andrew Cuomo lived in my town went to my
grandmother's church I am from exactly
the same place as the Cuomo family from
exactly the same ethnic background
Fredo is not the n-word for Italians it
is specifically an insult that is used
to make fun of Chris Cuomo and more
broadly it's an insult that's used to
make fun of the weak or stupid brother
or son in a prominent family this is an
insult it is an insult for stupid people
not for Italians it also can't be the N
word for Italians because Italians have
a lot of swear words curse words racial
epithets for themselves and for others
and so specifically the N word in the
italian-american community is actually
the M word it refers to a word that
comes from Italian and from Sicilian I'm
not gonna say the word but it's a word
for black people and it means eggplant
I guess because eggplants have kind of
dark I'm not even gonna get into it but
so that it actually would be the M word
it would be the direct parallel for the
N word and if we're talking about a
racial epithet for Italians there are a
lot of them they begin with the letter G
they begin with the letter W actually a
lot of them begin with the letter G
there are a lot of terms that
couldn't yeah they've been with the
letter D the one letter they don't begin
with is the letter F because Fredo is
not a racial epithet for Italians that
is weak sauce but I'm not surprised that
Cuomo jumped to that because the left
and CNN always jump to play the race
card whenever they can even when it's
absurd and it's virtually always absurd
when they do it and it's certainly
absurd in this case what he is referring
to it for those of you who haven't seen
the greatest movie ever made and the
second greatest movie ever made
Godfather Part 1 and then Godfather Part
2 here is the the irony of it all is
that someone calls Chris Cuomo Fredo and
then Chris Cuomo gets angry about this
and his reaction is immediately to
behave exactly like Fredo Corleone here
is from the movie you called me Fredo
but I'm not free to I'm smart hey I got
passed over for governor of New York
like my father Mario and my brother
Andrew but I'm smart I can do things I
could handle things not dumb like people
think that that was almost word-for-word
his response to this absolutely high
larious so then he doubled down so he
said this is a racial slur because
that's that's just what the left does
they play the race card the minute they
they feel threatened or they feel
insulted or they they feel like they
can't answer you
CNN though the the vice president and
spokesman for CNN Matt Dornoch doubled
down on this as well he wrote quote
Chris Cuomo defended himself when he was
verbally attacked with the use of an
ethnic slur in an orchestrated setup we
completely support him that first
sentence is almost entirely false every
there are three things that he said that
just are ridiculous verbally attacked
ethnic slur and orchestrated set up
he wasn't verbally attacked some guy
called him Fredo it's like a little
passing insult
it's not an attack we're not equate
experience here he didn't go assault him
Chris Cuomo assaulted him I mean he
literally threatened to do him physical
violence which we'll see in a second but
the guy didn't verbally attack him he
made fun of him he said he said hey
Fredo hey look at you Fredo then ethnic
slur it's not an ethnic slur we showed
that and then orchestrated setup no it's
not an orchestrated setup they were at a
restaurant here's what really happened a
dude at a restaurant saw Chris Cuomo and
made fun of him that's it that's all it
was not an ethnic slur not a were
castrated a setup not verbally attacked
here's how by the way if you don't need
to just take my word for it even though
I do have some expertise on this coming
from New York as someone of swarthy
complexion whose ancestors almost
certainly paddled a sardine boat over
from Palermo you don't need to just take
my expertise because I have proof that
CNN does not really think that Fredo is
an ethnic slur and that's because CNN
contributors and guests have repeatedly
used the term Fredo
to make fun of Republicans not even
Italian Americans just Republicans
here's fake Republican Anna Navarro
using the term Fredo on Chris Cuomo show
to make fun of Donald Trump jr. daddy
kept Fredo back home so who camps what
Donald Trump jr. says who cares what
Donald Trump jr. says all right I don't
want to talk about you is that a racial
slur is it a racial slur against what
the Scottish the Trump's is Scottish
right yes I guess Fredo's an ethnic slur
against the Italians and the Scots you
know I'm a little bit Scottish too it's
a it's also not an ethnic slur against
the Scots is it an offensive term toward
Don Jr yeah well they're basically
calling Don stupid done by the way Don
jr. is in no way the Fredo of the Trump
family but that's neither here nor there
probably just one time though right well
that's just one example Michael you're
picking out that well you have fortunate
how convenient one cherry-picked example
right nope here is Rick Wilson another
fake Republican also using the term on
CNN it's absolutely part of this this
you know that all the forces of society
are arrayed against this is just us and
Donald Trump against the world and look
Devin Nunez is proving himself again and
again to be the Fredo of the Republican
Party oh gosh an ethnic slur oh my
goodness is this the end of the world I
don't know Ryan Lizza and Anderson
Cooper who were on that show don't seem
to be reacting too strongly against it
any other examples yes the Boston Globe
ran a whole article titled quote is Don
Jr our era's Fredo Corleone
George Takei who played the character on
Star Trek a-- a million years ago he
retweeted it saying quote we should stop
calling jr. Don we should start calling
him Fredo
but actually you can even put all of
those aside because my evidence that
it's not an ethnic slur that that CNN or
Chris Cuomo even takes seriously is that
Chris Cuomo himself referred to himself
as Fredo we'll get to that in a second
then we'll get to what this means more
broadly for the culture wars but first I
have got to thank our friends over at
Lending Club because this is a message
for everybody everybody can let credit
card debt run away with them and
accumulate a ton of it and pay absurd
interest rates I'm specifically talking
to the fellas though because just
speaking from experience I know guys
tend to not pay attention and their
finances they let things run away women
can do it too though don't do it we have
this idea in our culture it's buy it now
pay for it later right everybody here is
this and that's how credit card
companies rope you in then they leave
out the part about paying it later with
interest Lending Club allows you to
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans which means no trips to the bank
that's great I almost never go to the
bank as it is because I'm a millennial
no high interest credit cards just go to
Lending Club calm you tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow you
pick the terms that are right for you if
you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days I
think people get let their finances run
away from with them not because they're
stupid not even because they're totally
irresponsible it's because they're a
little lazy they don't want to just do
the simple things they can do to save a
ton of money Lending Club is the number
one peer-to-peer lending platform with
over 35 billion dollars in loans issued
check it out right now right now go to
Lending
club.com / Knowles check your rate in
minutes borrow up to $40,000 at is
Lending Club calm / Knowles kinna WL is
lending love.com / Knowles all loans
made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender my final bit of evidence
that neither Chris Cuomo nor CNM
actually believes Fredo is an ethnic
slur is that Fredo I'm sorry Chris used
it to refer to himself and a New York
radio show hosted by Curtis sliwa here
is a group of people of politico's who
always hint that they might run but
don't necessarily plunge all the way and
they are members of la Cuomo Nostra yes
exactly so you better be careful the day
that your brother Andrew doesn't kiss
you on both cheeks and then all of a
sudden they take you out into the middle
of the lake and then where's Chris
alright this I've actually I've been at
political events with Curtis sliwa
classic New York character and this is
just a term it's a term that people used
to refer to a dumb people and they're in
a moment where Chris Cuomo wasn't being
sanctimonious and beating his own chest
where he was actually being a little
self effacing he referred to himself as
Fredo Cuomo because he is the Fredo of
the Cuomo family there's no doubt about
it I used to defend him
it's like he's actually my favorite
Cuomo I'll explain why in a second but
now I can't because he actually just
behaved like Fredo would behave I'm
smart I can handle things now in defense
of Cuomo I will say I think it's
perfectly fine to defend your own honor
especially if you're out there you're at
a restaurant or a beer garden or
whatever that is and you're there maybe
with your family maybe with some friends
and some jerk calls you an idiot I think
it's perfectly fine to defend your honor
I'm not one of these wallflowers you
know are these people who will say oh
never mind no it's okay I can never talk
back or never fight back no that's crazy
obviously Cuomo here had escalated it
but look if that happened to me I maybe
I would have talked back to the guy
hopefully I would have had better lines
than Ben Fredo Cuomo did because Fredo
escalates here's your's Fredo escalating
the fight
[Music]
[Music]
Richard stop I thought it was your name
you know what you were saying right I
thought it was
absolutely hilarious so obviously Fritos
the one who escalates it here and he
doesn't even use good languages so you
called me you can barely hear it cuz you
have to bleep out every word we you
called me effin Fredo
I'll call you Punk female dog I'll call
you this I'll throw you down that effin
flight of stairs
alright that's a actual elevation that
it just doesn't unless you're gonna back
it up it doesn't look good to threaten
something like that and then not do it
he's obviously not not going to do it so
if this happened to me I might talk back
but hopefully I would have some better
lines as a matter of prudence it's
probably better to walk away and he says
hey you're Fredo be like hey alright if
you say later bye bye you know you're
just gonna maybe flee when people would
yell at Scalia sometimes he would do he
just flick the underside of his chin
which people mistakenly people just
don't understand anything about the
italian-american culture because the
Washington Post I believe it was
reported that the flick underneath your
chin means f you it doesn't it means I
don't care I don't care what you say
maybe that's what I would have done if I
had been prudent and if Chris Cuomo had
been prudent that's what you could do my
guess he was at at a restaurant or a
beer garden maybe he had a couple adult
beverages a couple Coca Cola's he was
feeling a little bit Niskanen 10 per run
away with him this is not the end of the
world and it shouldn't be encouraged you
know what look I don't like getting
harassed in public by some jerk lefty
and he probably doesn't want to get
harassed in public by a hilarious right
winger so okay that's I don't think
people need to be harassing media
figures also though you do have to be
prepared for these sort of things to
happen because of another important
piece of advice in The Godfather part to
this from the Jewish gangster Hyman Roth
this is the business we've chosen let it
go
and I said to myself this is the
business we've chosen this is the
business we've chosen all right if
you're in the public space if you put
yourself out there in the public if you
go in the media then you're going to get
public criticism that's just the way it
is it's not good we should discourage it
you don't want to get accosted while
you're out with your family but that is
the sort of thing that you can get
accosted for and specifically the reason
why Chris Cuomo is a real hypocrite on
this is that Chris Cuomo himself on CNN
once attacked a 16 year old kid for
smirking
well a maniac accosted him he said he
shouldn't have even done that
here's Cuomo face-to-face encounter the
man Nathan Phillips apparently wanted to
defuse the tension and he walked up to
do exactly that and surely the kid Nix
Sandman he doesn't seem to be afraid but
he did make a choice and that was to
make it into a standoff that was not a
good choice was it legal sure that's not
my test and it shouldn't be the test
here's mine if that were my son who
happens to go to a great Catholic school
would I like what he did
if I were there would I have allowed the
kids to be in that situation
no and no there was a disrespect at play
that doesn't work for me in these
circumstances yeah definitely Fredo okay
that makes sense so you've got a 16 year
old kid who is doing nothing wrong other
than waiting for his school bus on the
Washington Mall he's being screamed at
by black supremacists called the Hebrew
Israelites calling him all sorts of
awful names then there's a leftist
lunatic activist a guy named nathan
phillips who marches up to the
sixteen-year-old kid starts banging a
drum in his face and this kid exhibits
saintly patience saintly restraint and
saintly prudence and Chris Cuomo attacks
him for it
because the kid didn't I don't know what
shine the guy's shoes or something but
the meanwhile some guy makes an offhand
comment to Chris Cuomo at a beer garden
or a restaurant or wherever they were
and koma loses his mind threatens to
thrown down a flight of stairs and
unleashes a stream of expletives maybe
maybe Chris Cuomo should call up that 16
year old kid Nix and ask him for advice
on how to handle public criticism on how
to handle public confrontations
absolutely ridiculous I do however have
just
just before we leave this fredo Cuomo
story get to more important things
I do have a very unpopular opinion Chris
Cuomo is my favorite Wilma he actually
is he is so much better than his brother
and father I'm obviously damning with
faint praise here because his brother
and father two of the worst political
figures in American history
his brother legalized the killing of
babies up until the point of birth in
New York State removed penal protections
such that if you if you murder a woman
who's pregnant no longer will that be
counted as a double murder that's only a
single murder even she's about to give
birth he lit up Freedom Tower in pink on
the day that he legalized infanticide in
New York his father also Mario Cuomo was
almost worse Mario Cuomo was the guy who
constructed the main political argument
for supporting abortion which is that
Mario and Andrew and I guess Chris are
nominally Catholic they don't really
seem to be Catholic because they support
murdering babies as they're being born
but what Mario did was he wanted to give
cover to geraldine ferraro who is
running as the first Catholic woman
pro-abortion vice presidential candidate
and so he gave her her cover by saying I
am personally opposed to abortion but I
think it should be totally legal I would
never impose my personal views on the
public what are you talking about you
impose your personal views on taxes on
health care on the our forms of
government on the judiciary you impose
your your personal views everywhere in
politics that's what politics is in a
representative democracy is you are
elected and then you use your judgment
in your views to to govern the country
and when you're voting you use your
personal views to elect people to
represent you in the government it's a
total BS also if you think that abortion
is tantamount to murder which is the
position of the Catholic Church and it's
ostensibly the position you're supposed
to hold then in what universe can you
say look I think murder is wrong
personally but I don't think we should
have any laws against murder
I can't impose my personal views against
murder on the public what nonsense is
that
and yet this became the main argument
for abortion supporters to give them
cover so Andrew and Mario are absolute
degenerates I mean absolutely horrible
people by comparison
Fredo ain't looking too bad he lost his
temper there but
I'll take him any day over those that
awful brother and his awful father
speaking of terrible people we've got to
get to the latest on Jeffrey Epstein CBS
News is now reporting quote there was
shrieking heard from Jeffrey Epstein's
jail cell the morning he died and you
know when you kill yourself you're
usually shrieking right probably
shrieking something to the effect of oh
no Hillary please don't good sense thing
that's the sound you make when you
commit suicide no I'm only kidding
so the first line of the piece says
quote on the morning of Jeffrey
Epstein's death there was shouting and
shrieking from his jail cell a source
familiar with the situation told CBS
News that doesn't sound great second
line is quote corrections officers
attempted to revive him while saying
quote breathe Epstein breathe so is it
not a well-written story because you
don't know if the shouting was from
Epstein or if it was from the guards or
the people who discovered his body
another inmate talking to another outlet
said that he heard nothing when Epstein
killed himself it was a perfectly silent
act now there's a raid on the private
island that Epstein owned the New York
Post is reporting that Jeffrey Epstein
used a bedsheet to hang himself and that
he was unattended for hours
again more lurid details are gonna come
out we still don't have that autopsy
it's all very suspicious even more
suspicious is a New York Times reporter
James B Stewart sat down with Epstein a
year ago and we didn't get this at the
time because the interview was unbound
so Epstein said yeah I'll talk to you
but it's gonna be on background so you
can't use my name what the reporter said
is now that Epstein is dead he thinks
that that is no longer binding and I
think that's a fair principle so here is
what the guy learned the New York Times
reporter he said he walked into
Epstein's giant mansion and there was a
young girl in her late teens or maybe 20
who opened the door she looked like she
was from Eastern Europe he thought wow
this guy's so flagrantly just showing
off his and flaunting his preference for
underage girls
he sent then said Epstein showed him a
photo of Mohammed bin Salman Crown
Prince of Saudi Arabia
he said that Mohammed bin Solomon had
visited Epstein many times and that they
spoke frequently now with all of his
claims you never know if Epstein is
biessing or if it's true
because he's obviously a con man but on
the other hand he's hung around with a
lot of powerful people some of the most
powerful people in the world including
two US presidents we also know that
Epstein was issued a Saudi passport so
he's clearly got some a relationship
with Saudi Arabia and if he is a big sex
trafficker that wouldn't be very
surprising then Epstein showed the
reporter photos with Bill Clinton and
Woody Allen two of the best known sexual
degenerates in America
he then implied that he was advising
Elon Musk and Tesla
he then waxed philosophical how awful it
was to criminalize sex with teenage
girls how for most of history this was
perfectly acceptable so he's speaking
like a guy who genuinely has the sexual
preference for young girls and he was
saying it's beautiful it's a wonderful
thing how awful he compared it to
homosexuality so that was long
considered a crime but now it's no
longer considered a crime he told this
reporter that he had seen a lot of
prominent tech figures doing drugs and
arranging for sex
Epstein apparently never drank or did
any drugs just underage girls the the
reporter then got a call from Epstein a
week later asking if he wanted to have
dinner with Woody Allen and Epstein he
then got a call a week after that asking
if he wanted to have dinner with Michael
Wolfe the author of that trash book
about the Trump administration and Steve
Bannon former Breitbart head and former
strategist for Trump did these dinners
happen we don't know were these guys in
it Epstein's orbit maybe we don't know
some of them obviously were but maybe
not all of them Epstein then asked the
reporter to write a biography of Epstein
and the reporter said he thought that
Epstein just wanted companionship he
just wanted someone to talk to
the reporter turned it down so now we
don't have the details from that
biography probably would have been
pretty interesting that the portrait
that's being painted here in this New
York Times piece is one of a hustler and
a con man so maybe not this
international man of mystery more than
just a really really successful common
hustler
maybe that's the image being painted
again we don't know all you can take are
these little pictures I mean these guys
do exist
real hardcore hustlers do exist
especially in New York I've met a few of
them but here's the key here's the key
from from the reporter the overriding
impression I took away from our roughly
90 minute conversation was that mr.
Epstein knew an astonishing number of
rich famous and powerful people and had
photos to prove it he also claimed to
know a great deal about these people
some of it potentially damaging or
embarrassing including details about
their suppose sexual proclivities and
recreational drug use
Vanity Fair doubled down on this they
got bombshell information about the
private sex island from Ghislaine
Maxwell Epstein's partner in crime we
will get to that in one second plus a
few more stories that we just can't miss
today but first I have got to say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube and by
the way you're almost out of time to
purchase tickets to our backstage live
show August 21st at the incredible
Terrace Theatre in Long Beach California
you'll get Ben Shapiro daily wire
god-king Jeremy boring Andrew Clavin and
most importantly me chopping up the
winners and losers of politics and pop
culture best of all we will be answering
your questions from the audience
tickets are available at daily wired.com
slash backstage there are still a few
VIP ticket packages available these
include premium seating photos and meet
and greets with all of us a gift from
Ben and more they are selling very fast
that we don't have a lot of VIP packages
left I don't even know if we have a lot
of regular tickets left so head over
there fast because this is coming up
daily wire.com slash backstage get yours
today head over to daily wire.com we'll
be right back with a lot more
so we got this bombshell out of Vanity
Fair I mean it's hard to call it a
bombshell every story in the Epstein
saga seems to be a bombshell but they do
keep coming out and this is from Vanity
Fair a bit specifically about Ghislaine
Maxwell who was that
British socialite whose father was a
zillionaire who had connections to the
KGB and possibly Mossad to foreign
intelligence agencies he was kind of an
international man of mystery died under
strange circumstances
Ghislaine Maxwell was hanging around
Epstein all the time and this is from
the article quote on the weekends in the
1990s Maxwell would have her roller
blades FedEx to Epstein's island in the
Caribbean and said she got her
helicopters license so she could
transport anyone she liked without
pilots knowing who they were
Maxwell also said the island had been
completely wired for video the friend
thought that she and Epstein were
videotaping everyone on the island as an
insurance policy as blackmail sounds
about right I mean that the helicopter
thing is really big we read before that
Maxwell was flying people on helicopter
the reason to fly people on helicopter
over there is then you don't need to
hire the pilots for the private jet so
for instance if somebody like a Bill
Clinton or a prime minister of somewhere
or a very important figure wants to get
to that island without having to really
disclose it without really being noticed
if you keep it that close where it's not
even a staffer but it's one of the
business partners for Epstein romantic
partner Epstein coming up in the one
flying them over that raises serious
questions I mean that's a very very
convenient plus the idea that everything
was wired so you had cameras you had
photos apparently when SD NY raided the
mansion the largest private residence in
Manhattan owned by Epstein that they
found compromising material on different
people so it does seem like there was a
big blackmail scheme going on here the
question is was it a state-backed
conspiracy war was Maxwell just a kook
this is what Vanity Fair says quote a
source close to Maxwell says she spoke
Wibbly and confidently about getting
girls to sexually service Epstein saying
this was simply what he wanted and
describing the way she drive around to
spas and trailer parks in Florida to
recruit them she would claim she had a
phone job for them end quote you'll make
lots of money meet everyone and I'll
change your life so who knows who knows
I mean she obviously had this personal
relationship there's apparently this
weird sex temple at Elle looks like an
Egyptian sort of temple on the private
island I mean there are some weird kooky
stuff going on here we don't know if
it's state-backed we don't know if it's
backed by some international organized
crime cabal we don't know if it's just a
supervillain and his creepy girlfriend
what we do know is we need to talk to
get slain Maxwell for her whereabouts
are apparently unknown right now I
wouldn't be surprised if she weren't
hiding but obviously she's one of the
only people if not the only person who
can provide information on what was
going on and so I assume the authorities
are looking for her but she's the only
way that this story isn't going to
completely die with Jeffrey Epstein
though it may already be too late
speaking of too late might be too late
for our culture as a matter of fact here
in the West because there is a story
coming out it went viral you've heard of
these drag queen reading hours for
little children at libraries why this is
happening there's no good reason why
this is happening I mean the real reason
that it's happening is so that the
cultural left can indoctrinate and
inculcate these bizarre ideas and
children at a very young age but there's
no good reason for this to happen why
would you have grown men who think that
their women are dress up like women who
sexualized themselves sitting around
with small children reading them stories
well at a UK library a drag queen
recently taught kids how to twerk as
seen on a viral video that was then
promoted by the library relax do some
this funny little dances from fortnight
does anybody know I need the dancing
fortnight oh then you are a credit to
your community but most of all Michael
likes to twerk now does anybody in this
room know how to twerk
yeah but it's quite important to the
story so I will just give you a very
quick demonstration all you need to do
is you just stand to your feet sort of
shoulder-width apart like so okay I'll
show you the sides you can better be
there and if you're crouched down into
this sort of position you see your thumb
sticking out and then you just move your
thumb up and down like that and that's
twerking if you were only listening to
that and you haven't seen that yet you
are blessed you are so fortunate I would
that I could be you but I did see it and
twerking for those who don't know is
when you basically just simulate the
sexual movements I mean a lot of modern
dancing quote unquote is that but
twerking is kind of the logical extrema
but where you're just kind of shifting
your hips back and forth and thrusting
your pelvis and that and putting your
derriere out in the air that's what this
dude in a dress was doing in front of
toddlers pulls up his skirt a little bit
and then starts shaking his derriere and
the library bragged about this on social
media there is no excuse for this there
is no justification for this not in the
name of open-mindedness not in the name
of tolerance or inclusion or culture or
liberalism or diversity or anything this
is the extreme of sexualizing material
for little tiny children and before you
have the knee-jerk reaction some on the
left of this knee-jerk reaction of oh
you're transphobic or homophobic or
phobic phobic or whatever nonsense words
they invent ask yourself what is what is
the purpose of this what is accomplished
by this it's what is accomplished it
desensitizes kids to bizarre sexual
proclivities it desensitizes kids to
sexualized material maybe it makes hyper
sexualized or uncommon lay sexualized
people feel more in the mainstream of
society but why are we trying to
mainstream bizarre sexual activities and
delusions and certainly I mean you would
know if you had just a
regular old straight white male guy
we're in I don't know a oxford shirt and
a pair of chinos walk into that library
and say hey guys my name's Keith I'm a
regular middle-aged white guy and I'm
gonna read you a book today but before I
do that I'm going to thrust my pelvis in
the air repeatedly and then stick out my
derriere and make sure that all you
little kids can see it the guy would be
arrested in two seconds but because this
guy I don't even know his name the drag
queen can claim a victim status because
the people who are putting them up to
this can claim a victim status they can
get away with anything
this is why victimhood is such a
valuable currency and whenever someone
is claiming victimhood you should
immediately be skeptical of what they're
talking about because they are using
that as a protective shield to get away
with things that regular old people
wouldn't get away with it's happening in
the UK and it's happening throughout the
United States that video happens to be
from the United Kingdom but we've seen
similar incidents here and it's it's
only getting worse and the key to it is
the victim culture the more you allow a
victim culture to exist the more you try
to co-opt victim culture even you're
playing a losing game it's a Faustian
bargain that is going to lose you all of
your cultural premises speaking of the
culture wars Washington Post is furious
at Trump they say quote from race two
plastic straws Trump dials up the
culture wars for twenty twenty votes
see Trump is engaging in the culture
wars and that's bad the left they don't
engage in the culture wars right the
left is the culture war they are the
storm they are the culture war Trump is
simply fighting back against the culture
wars he's engaging in them yeah but he's
he dialling them up no he's simply
responding to them here's here's how I
can prove it to you
we had straws with plastic straws in
this country and it was fine everything
was totally fine and it didn't bother
anybody then one day a nine-year-old
child in Canada did a study for a class
report and he came up with this
ridiculous number that said that we're
using a zillion gazillion or however
many straws per day and this is
destroying the planet
and because of that
and because of leftist activism we had
to get rid of all of our plastic straws
and now we use that mushy pulp that
won't let us drink our drinks
that was the aggression in the culture
war it serves no purpose it won't save
the environment it won't do anything to
the natural environment it just makes
our life less convenient it just makes
it harder to drink a milkshake that was
a massive aggression in the culture war
taking away straws from hundreds of
millions of people but then you see when
we point out we fight back we say
actually I think we should keep our
straws they say you're regressing you're
fighting the culture war no I'm not I'm
just I just think it was fine and then
you invented a problem out of nothing
and then you took away my plastic straws
which makes my drinking habits much more
inconvenient they say yeah you're
dialing up the culture worse no of
course we're not all of this they say
you conservatives are so obsessed with
sex
what do you talk what are you talking
about we're not the ones dragging drag
queens into public libraries to twerk
for three-year-olds we're not the ones
radically redefining the central human
institution marriage which has had the
same definition more or less or at least
a similar definition for all of human
history everywhere in the world
you're the ones doing that and then when
we say hmm maybe that's not the best
idea maybe we should be a little
cautious about this you accuse us of
being the aggressors in the culture work
we're not and it's this lie the people
who say Trump should shut up
Trump should stop tweeting he should
stop talking about football or straws or
Bette Midler that washed-up psycho
singer he should stop talking about that
you just don't get it
we tried just talking about tax rates we
tried it we had Mitt Romney and he lost
we had Paul Ryan who I really like he
wasn't successful John McCain just tried
to talk about you know taxes and not
social issues he lost we look that's a
losing strategy no one cares about
bean-counting no one cares and one wakes
up in a cold sweat and says oh we need
to reduce the marginal tax rate on that
upper quintile of income earners no no
one cares it's all the culture and the
left knows this that's why the left has
been running through our cultural
institution
for 50 years and the minute
conservatives fight back all of a sudden
this is a big issue the the Washington
Post wants to make it a big issue
because they know how potent it is they
know that the only way that we're gonna
win is by fighting back on the culture
two examples you have two presidential
candidates sitting US senators lying
through their teeth demonstrably about a
racially divisive incident that occurred
years ago in the killing of Michael
Brown he was a black young man who was
killed by a cop here's what Kamala
Harris said quote Michael Browns murder
forever changed Ferguson in America his
tragic death sparked a desperately
needed conversation and a nationwide
movement we must fight for stronger
accountability and racial equity in our
justice system he wasn't murdered
Elizabeth Warren five years ago Michael
Brown was murdered by a white police
officer in Ferguson Missouri Michael was
unarmed yet he was shot six times I
stand with activists and organizers who
continue to fight for justice for
Michael we must confront systemic racism
and police violence head-on this is a
complete fiction this is a completely
made-up narrative this is the narrative
you heard of hands up don't shoot that
all the congressman did this is the the
narrative that he was hit from behind
Michael Brown he was running away he was
hit from behind none of that happened
how do I know none of that happened well
don't take my word for it voxcom and the
Washington Post both admit this was a
total lie
from Warren and from Kamala Harris and
broadly from the Left wopo to their
credit gave at four Pinocchios Michael
Brown young man robbed a store then
comes out a cop pulls up on him Michael
Brown reaches into the cop car grabs the
cops gun so he wasn't unarmed he was
grabbing the cops gun then according to
multiple witnesses of different races a
young biracial man and older black man
other witnesses as well according to
multiple autopsies he was not shot from
behind and he was grabbing the gun
inside the cop car total lies totally
racially divisive talk about cultural
issues that is being pushed by the left
peddling lies and yet Donald Trump
stands up for some common sense some at
least grasping toward the truth and all
of a sudden we're told it's the worst
thing in the world and conservatives
need to sit down and shut up you're
dividing the country you're racist your
whites
premises to look at this trash from
these people I mean they should be so
ashamed of themselves for spreading this
racial bigotry these horrible racial
laws Liz Warren and Kamala Harris next
time a left winger calls you a racist
look your fingers under your chin who
cares they have no credibility on this
it's despicable you owe them no answer
no explanation
they are so guilty of racial division
racial hatred and bigotry who cares what
they think
before we go I have to talk about maybe
the most important story of the day at
the pan-american games a fencer and a
hammer thrower protests of the United
States the fencer race Imboden of course
that guy's a fencer of kinding race
Imboden
I can you imagine what prep school he
went to can you imagine how much cheri
he drank in the evening when he was
growing up
race Imboden a fencer took a knee at the
pan-american games to protest President
Trump and America I guess he was really
pissed off and couldn't just saber the
moment and certainly wasn't sitting on
the fence about his politics that's
another Tsar all of the fencing puns
that I know so thank you for indulging
me in that what an idiot though well
total jerk he another guy this guy Gwen
Barry also he's a hammer thrower he also
protested America at the Pan American
Games which is something I had never
heard of until this political dust-up
and here's what race Imboden the fencer
said he tweeted it out he tweeted at his
picture of his kneeling he said quote we
must call for change this week I'm
honored to represent Team USA at the Pan
Am Games taking home gold and bronze my
pride however has been cut short by the
multiple shortcomings of the country I
hold so dear to my heart
racism gun control mistreatment of
immigrants and a president who spreads
hate are at the top of a long list now
this is a little confusing because as
he's saying he hates gun control says
racism mistreatment of immigrants the
president who spreads hate and gun
control those are all
things he hates or he likes gun control
that then does he like racism and the
mistreatment of immigrants and president
no and that he's not probably not if I'm
gonna guess the brightest bulb in the
pack where the sharpest tool in the shed
or the sharpest saber in the head oh no
he goes on quote I chose to sacrifice my
moment today at the top of the podium to
call attention to issues that I believe
need to be addressed I encourage others
to please use your platform for
empowerment and change you didn't
sacrifice anything actually you just
stole a moment in public you just stole
15 minutes of fame nobody would have
ever heard your name unique as it is
nobody would have ever heard really
about your sporting activities no one
would have ever heard about the Pan Am
Games except that you took a moment that
was supposed to honor people's athletic
achievements and through those
achievements their countries and you
stole it for yourself to make a stupid
political point that undermines the
entire purpose of games sports and
certainly international athletic
competitions
that's the only reason anyone's talking
about him when was the last time people
were talking about fencing
like never at least not in a hundred
years sports are supposed to be about
taking the ego and having it be subsumed
into something bigger and greater
pushing down your ego and building up a
country a sport a team that's
sportsmanship that's being a team player
you're on the you're representing the
United States this is especially true of
international games but they don't get
it this guy doesn't get it because he is
obsessed with his own ego as his Colin
Kaepernick as are all of the idiots who
take a knee in protest the American flag
it's despicable
he should be immediately removed from
the team he should not represent the
United States he's chosen not to
represent the United States
well first he chose to do it and then he
chose to spit on the United States he
should not be permitted to compete in
professional sports as a representative
the United States and we should we this
is the battle the battle isn't over
taxes the battle isn't over slight
changes to the bureaucracy this is the
battle it's a battle for the heart and
soul of America and it's a battle for a
love of country and jerks who don't love
their country certainly shouldn't be the
one
representing it that's our show come
back tomorrow we got a lot more to get
through we'll do it then in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show see you tomorrow
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover technical producer Austin
Stephens editor Danny D'Amico our audio
mixer is Mike Cora Meena hair and makeup
by Jesuit alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
they'll get a whole lot of that and much
more we'll see you there